I'm here today with two of my good
friends at BuzzFeed I am going to show
them a tasty video once through they
have all the ingredients they've got no
instructions and they're gonna have to
make it do you think that you can do it
no it's like chicken but it's a lot of
stuff there's a lot working together
right so I think like our brain pairs
combined maybe so she's like thinking
you're not helping me over him but I
also fun fact don't release hutch Romney
me either I was just looking at how
slimy that is so this will be fun so
today y'all are gonna be making a
classic tasty recipe one pot chicken
bacon spinach Alfredo
a lot of stuff in there I like a whole
thing I think I felt like it was like a
very natural for in the cooking one pot
recipes are very accessible yes so I
think that you'll be able to and that's
a big barrier for me for cooking it's
just like doing dishes I don't like to
do dishes either yeah which is why
shakeout is my friend all right ready
mm-hmm
bacon six strips
would you remember oh yeah that looks so
watery Oh chicken breasts to just say
how much time or have what heat but that
was so fast
[Music]
it wasn't dump it off okay I don't even
know if order manners anymore okay oh
[Music]
wait but it was bacon chicken spinach
salt pepper oh boy
I think I think we got it oh that looks
good it's just look good
oh I want to eat that right now okay I'm
motivated
I am foo cuz I want some yes well gifts
all that just becomes from the pages of
the books amazing
okay who wants to touch the raw meat
maybe somebody cut bacon - someone cut
chicken okay don't do it on the same
don't do don't do it on the same cutting
board
why because tasty readers will be mad
and this is hard to cut
okay the making itself fatty and yeah I
can feel that I'm making good fun that I
eat meat but I literally never make
anything with meat hardly ever Yemen
entire don't like to touch yes I'm like
nervous punching them cut this movie
should we cut it a certain way I
literally don't use these I'm a stem no
make a claw rather than have your
fingers out there like hold it like that
your fingernails oh so I'm not like
asking if you like you literally were
about to cut your fingers okay noted oh
my god I just feel like I'm cut it into
like flesh and it's grossing me out
well what are the chances that we both
don't know how to cook we have other
talent yes that's right just call one of
y'all cuts your fingers off I feel like
it's definitely gonna be my fault it
will be you'll get the bill smaller I
cans are any questions it our lives are
at stake here your life is that fake cuz
you have to eat this right listen I've
had salmonella before what guy I've had
Salmonella and e-coli I just have a very
adventurous Peter I take a lot of
chances we're the opposite I am going to
push the bacon that I have cut in the
pot
I actually like cooking the bacon in
here cuz I get afraid of like the oil
splattering you know and I feel like
this will cover it more I'm scared Sam
been over it cuz I don't want to go pass
on them I know you're looking right in
there yeah that does some good I brought
y'all a little snack oh good that is
that good
okay this is running here we keep it all
together no but they took it out and
then they cut the other stuff in because
you have to boil the pasta we do the
pasta and then we put the chicken and
bacon back in at the end
I remember that Selena I'm charlie you
mean if you look I could kill a man with
this book I just love how you're cutting
that garlic I know I'm just trying to
get it done you know
this is a trick this I've seen Thank You
hell yeah baby Minton okay yeah good
Acosta right we don't put any water just
know am i doing something wrong
should we boil it first I think we need
more milk if that comes to a boil it's
gonna boil right off and evaporate right
are we guys yeah we're doing or doing it
we're both signing off there it is yeah
like just go for it yeah but not too
much no keep going should I do it off do
it off okay yeah executive decision
once this starts to boil we basically
just throw everything back in just the
cheese oh that's one of the last things
yeah you know I'm proud of my girls yeah
yeah do you mean it yeah okay so we
should start adding spinach who do you
think that looks like a yeah that's a
nice keeping of oh that's a lot and
it'll like make it healthy yeah yeah
some pinches of salt ooh
sabe if this one's out good eye this is
something I will make the whistle yeah
if it turns out good yeah that's a big
if okay so let's add back in our chicken
and bacon is this jus supposed to be up
in there but I feel like this is about
to be boom a watery with this with the
chicken juice a bacon grease but bacon
grease makes stuff good yeah
it looks pretty good I've had the garlic
that's a lot of garlic I'm sorry
everybody I love garlic though me too
it's getting thicker like me yeah after
I eat this it smell good why do you want
to taste the plastic sure you have more
faith in our men yes yes okay it's very
hot though pop down there are we good in
any of them it's a little tough there's
no good minute would you say it's a
little tough but the flavors really good
are we're just doing all this cheese yes
let's just do it off that is something
I'm not going to skimp on boom oh I
think that's gonna make me Wow
ya know do we need more spinach it's not
that green right maybe if I give it a
good stir it's not so good does yeah I'm
really happy about this we start to
taste it though get a load of that
yeah how looks good
Wow look at that just steam rising
around it but dramatic if you're done I
would probably turn the mom and wait it
looks pretty good I feel like we work
together as a team we did yeah what did
you think so couple notes I would have
cooked the spinach first and that's what
they did in the video
that's why it's a lot greener in the
video than it is here I also would have
added the cheese off the heat on the
heat should we have that again I'm going
in here I want some bake I'm gonna get a
little bit of everything
yeah I don't know if I should follow
behind you though because you've had a
lot of food oh babe that's not bad any
more seasoning yeah even for me it's
bland it needs a lot more salt I think
that that's like the biggest mistake
that a lot of people make when they're
cooking is that they don't add enough
salt this is like you want to like oh
that's a still problem man at that
better already better yeah still could
use even maybe more yeah I want to be
mad at more and garlic either yeah I
really screwed up the seasoning
you should have added a little bit more
garlic but also if you cooked it with
the spinach you would have gotten more
of a garlicky flavor you didn't have
enough time for your garlic to like
infuse with the garlic so this will
probably taste even better tomorrow
one thing settling
like lasagna yeah oh I just got a whole
negative salt I get to but I like them
like the chicken is cooked well the
bacons cooked well listen we keep going
back in so I wouldn't say it's like my
favorite thing I've ever eaten but well
we know that Bob yeah I will say that
I'm actually really impressed for two
people who have pretty much and you'll
only watch the video once and you didn't
take the instructions right so I think
that you guys did a really good job I'm
really proud of you
what else do you guys want to see us
cook next or do next I want to have them
build something for their houses no I
will build something if you contour your
face okay obviously I can't really do
that either so okay there it is let's do
that drop us a comment below what we
should do next
[Music]